- [Interviewer] Some of
these look a little more-
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Rough.
- It's hard out here, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So, Ashley,
how long have you been here?
- For five or six years.
- [Interviewer] Five or six years.
- Since I was 18.
- [Interviewer] Since you were 18.
How old are you now?
- 25.
- [Interviewer] 25.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
- [Ashley] Well, when I was
six, I went into foster care.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you did?
- Uh-huh. So I was in
and out of foster care
'til I was like 13 and then once I was 13
my grandma put me into foster
care first, permanently.
- [Interviewer] And foster
care means what? You were...
- Like she gave up. Because like...
she gave up on the community.
- [Interviewer] Did you
have parents, at that point?
- My mom was a crack addict.
My dad died of a heroin overdose
when I was six. So...yeah.
And then I ran away from group homes
and I was on the run from 13 to 18.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- And then I was, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then
you ended up down here?
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] At some
point. And, you're living...?
- I came down here looking for heroin,
because I didn't know where to find it
when I came from Mexico. I was in Mexico
for a couple of years and
that's where I got strung out.
And then I came back to LA,
'cause me and my boyfriend broke up there
and yeah, I didn't know
where to find any heroin.
So that's how I ended up on Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] There's heroin here?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And heroin,
you started doing at about age...
- 18.
- [Interviewer] 18?
- Yeah. So...no, 18 and...
I came here when I was 19, so 18 and 19.
It was a year. I was in Mexico,
strung out and then I
came straight from Mexico
on the train to, what's
it called? Union Station?
- [Interviewer] Union Station, right here.
- [Ashley] Yeah, right here.
- [Interviewer] And do you have a family,
other than your siblings?
- [Ashley] Yeah, I have two
sisters and two brothers.
All younger, except my twin brother.
He's one minute older.
- [Interviewer] Did you talk to them?
- [Ashley] Um...not really. No.
- [Interviewer] And do
you have a boyfriend
or anything like that down here?
- [Ashley] I'm with a guy,
I'm staying with a guy now in East LA.
I met him down here. He's
not really my boyfriend,
but I kind of have to like pretend he is,
you know, to stay there.
- [Interviewer] And what
are you doing for money?
Like what's...the girls are doing...?
- [Ashley] Prostitution.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. How
long have you been doing that?
Since about...
- [Ashley] Since like, 19
since I came down here. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have crazy stories there?
Because a lot of the girls have, like...
- [Ashley] Yeah. Well I got kidnapped
for four days and raped.
They took me over to
Hoover and Imperial Highway
and held me there for like four days.
And that's where I learned,
you know I learned a lot
from that experience,
not to go with any Black guys,
and to really trust my
intuition with the guys
that I go with.
So now, yeah, I don't
go with any Black guys.
- [Interviewer] How'd you how'd you end up
getting out of that situation?
- [Ashley] Well, they were...the
guy and his girlfriend,
They were high on meth.
And so they fell asleep after four days
and the girl left the
keys 'cause I was locked.
It was all barred windows and barred...
you know those black
doors, those screen doors
that are metal?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And it had a lock from the inside
and I snuck in the room and
I saw that the keys were
inside this little plastic
Rubbermaid drawers.
I could see them.
So I got a washcloth and I
picked up the keys quietly
and there's like a thousand keys
and I just tried them on
and I finally got out,
and I just ran, with no
shoes and half-naked.
Yeah. I looked so bad.
It was really embarrassing.
I was really sick.
Really had to get something to get well.
- [Interviewer] It's great
that you got out though.
- Yeah, thank God.
I don't know what they
were gonna do with me.
They said they were going
to pimp me out, but...
I don't think that they would
have been able to trust me.
Maybe they would have
killed me or something.
I don't know. It's really scary.
So now, now I always have like,
weapons with me and stuff.
(interviewer laughs)
- So I don't want that to ever happen.
- [Interviewer] It's very dangerous.
- Yeah, it is.
- [Interviewer] Where would
you like to see yourself
in five years? What would
you like to be doing?
Do you have kids?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No kids.
- No, thank God.
I want kids, but not like this.
Hopefully I'll be sober, you know,
have my own place and have a job.
Probably be just getting on my feet,
but I like to be without a guy
doing my own thing.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Or a good guy, at least.
- [Ashley] Yeah. A good guy.
Not somebody I have to be with,
Just like how I'm with this guy now.
- [Interviewer] They're out there.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Well Ashley, thank you for talking to me.
- Yeah! No problem.
- [Interviewer] I appreciate it.
- Thank you.